[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
me acompaña en el estudio más Romero
sala mar bienvenida buena mañana de
jueves y Vamos a repasar las cifras de
vacunación en Colombia vacunación contra
el 19 porque como sabemos la pandemia No
termina esta vez centrándonos en algunos
grupos más vulnerables Buenos días es un
informe que se publicó la universidad
publicó la Universidad Nacional de
Colombia también con oxfam médicos del
mundo entre otros y que repasan hasta
Julio de 2022 como había avanzado la
vacunación contra el 19 por ejemplo en
poblaciones como la población indígena y
la población afro Vamos a repasar
primero que todo las cifras no vemos
este mapa el único lugar donde se
superan el 70% de vacunación contra el
19 Bogotá otro departamento también en
el central como boyacá en este caso Pero
en cambio vemos Que departamentos que
pues aquí en Colombia sabemos que
tradicionalmente son de población afro
de población indígena estamos hablando
del chocó por ejemplo pero también de
vichada guainía vaupés las tasas de
vacunación son mucho más bajas con la
excepción del Amazonas donde se hizo una
campaña muy intensa por todas las
conexiones que tenía con Brasil y porque
también fue uno de los lugares más
golpeados por el Kobe 19 al inicio de la
pandemia No eso tiene consecuencias
Vamos a repasar las tasas de mortalidad
por grupo poblacional también por Kobe
19 en Colombia vemos que la tasa general
es de un 2,54% tanto en el caso de la
población indígena como de la población
afro supera el 3%, no se puede atribuir
únicamente a la falta de vacuna y otros
factores que influyen pero
definitivamente nos da indicadores de
que hay una necesidad No atendida entre
estas poblaciones madre Cuáles son los
motivos que explican esta desigualdad de
la vacunación contra la pandemia Pues el
informe apunta varias causas primero hay
un tema de acceso geográfico y de
infraestructura Vial o de transporte
para llegar a estos territorios que es
bien compleja también A falta una falta
de reconocimiento digamos del Estado
precisamente porque no existen esos
lugares no hay infraestructuras por
ejemplo de salud pública que garanticen
los derechos de las poblaciones que
viven en estas zonas más apartadas o
también en algunos casos por casos de
conflicto armado por ejemplo donde las
autoridades pues no es el estado sino
son otras además también muchas de estas
poblaciones basan su existir en una
cosmovisión muy distinta en una medicina
tradicional y la desconfianza del Estado
también hace que desconfíen pues de todo
lo que es una medicina que no es la que
ellas conocen precisamente un equipo de
Franz 24 fue a entrevistar los autores
del estudio para apuntar algunas
soluciones a esto
Entonces el sistema tiene que adaptarse
a las necesidades de las comunidades y
no al revés no que las comunidades se
adapten al sistema Entonces sí creo que
hay unas personas hay que hacer un
esfuerzo grande para que el sistema
llegue a estos territorios reconozca su
cosmovisión reconozcan su Dios en Gracia
valoren en la medicina ancestral y
logren generar una confianza que
facilite que las personas accedan a los
servicios de salud no son la vacuna del
covid sino la demás oferta que el
sistema debe garantizarles para que
tengan el negocio efectivo de su derecho
a la salud también nos hablaban de
diferencias y de soluciones más a gran
escala Como por ejemplo con el tema de
las patentes y de hacer mención también
a quienes vinieron a quienes
entrevistaron a estas personas fueron
Marina sardiña compañera también de
salud y la camarógrafa Juanita González
escuchemos mientras la mayoría de la
población del planeta cayó en pobreza y
en pobreza extrema un pequeño grupo se
hizo mil millonaria a costas de la
atención y de la vacunación del covid
Entonces eso no Uno de nuestras apuestas
es lograr esa Liberación lograr que el
que haya la posibilidad de transferencia
de conocimientos de tecnología y que se
pueda producir desde el suro global a
menor costo y de buena calidad la
vacunación Bueno madre cambiamos de tema
porque desde Barcelona su tierra llegan
buenas noticias en la lucha contra el
cáncer si una noticia que además también
me hace especial ilusión anunciar
precisamente por eso no es una un nuevo
fármaco que hay que se está estudiando
contra el cáncer había dado ya muy
buenos resultados en febrero de este año
lo habíamos anunciado de hecho tuvimos a
una de las desarrolladoras aquí
entrevistada en salud de France 24 había
dado muy buenos resultados en cáncer
metastásico de mama particularmente en
laboratorios y en animales ahora estamos
en un estudio fase uno ya en humanos se
llama el fármaco homomix desarrollado
por el instituto de oncología del
hospital vall d'hebron son 22 pacientes
que han estado recibiendo este
tratamiento a lo largo de varios meses
en unos estudios en uno de los grupos de
estos pacientes 12 de ellos
particularmente 8 se les estabilizaron
sus tumores tumores además de varios
tipos de cáncer no era cáncer de mama
particularmente es decir que dejaron de
crecer después de nueve semanas de
tratamientos y además los efectos
secundarios que muchos tratamientos
contra el cáncer sabemos que son muy
agresivos fueron relativamente leves no
estamos hablando por ejemplo de náuseas
vómitos de una bajada de tensión después
de la inoculación del fármaco entonces
bueno digamos que en este sentido
todavía son resultados preliminares Pero
son buenas noticias y qué debería pasar
para que este tratamiento llegue al
público el camino es largo no vamos a
decir que no al menos faltan dos fases
más de estudio que deben durar además
varios meses en el que se va ampliando
cada vez más el grupo de pacientes que
reciben el tratamiento podría hacer por
ejemplo hasta 2027 más o menos que
realmente llegue a los a los pacientes
que se use ampliamente no eso no quita
que sean buenas noticias desde el primer
fármaco que logra inhibir una una
llamada mic de ahí viene el nombre o
momic es una proteína que permiten
muchísimos de tipo muchísimos tipos de
cáncer Pues que las células cancerosas
se nutran se dividan y migran a otras
partes del cuerpo es decir hagan
metástasis no Además pues este tiempo
que puede faltar por recorrer es poco En
comparación con el tiempo que llevan los
científicos trabajando en esto
recordamos de esa entrevista que nos
daba una de sus desarrolladores en
febrero nos decía que llevaba 20 años
estudiando este tipo de tratamiento Así
que Bueno estamos en el último tramo
Bueno una buena noticia para cerrar este
segmento de salud del día de hoy
Muchísimas gracias mañana Por supuesto
más salud en directo América